We're learning today.
The man accused of brutally attacking
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi's
husband, Paul with a hammer
was in the US illegally.
He's Canadian and now he may be deported.
CNN's Veronica
Miracle is following
these developments for us.
Veronica,
what more are you learning
about what David de Pap
was doing in the US in the first place?
Well, we understand,
according to federal records,
that David de
Pap was a Canadian citizen
who was here on a temporary visa.
We're told that
he entered the country
through the California Mexico border
back in March.
Now, Canadian residents are allowed
to be in the US
on temporary visas
for up to six months at a time.
But those federal records state
that he overstayed that visa.
So ICE has issued a detainer on him,
which essentially means
that they've asked authorities
to notify them in the case that he were
to ever be released on air.
So how could this
development impact the case?
So we understand that
this is really unlikely
to have an impact
on his case immediately.
These immigration issues
are often resolved
after criminal issues are settled.
So in the case that he would
ever be deported
and the US were to seek that
that would happen
after a potential conviction
and after a potential prison sentence
on a depleted and entered
not guilty
pleas for all of his felony charges.
For that, the state has issued him
including assault with a deadly weapon,
attempted murder,
burglary, elder abuse, among others.
He faces up to 13 years
into life in prison for those charges.
And Congresswoman
Jackie Speier has actually said that
the state
could consider
charging him with a hate crime.
Here's what the San
Francisco district attorney
Brooke Jenkins, had to say about that.
Possibility.
Of course, we'll be
looking into everything
that we believe is
a crime that he violated at this point.
That is not something
that that we saw fit to charge.
But we certainly,
as well as the federal government,
will be looking at
what charges
we will proceed on going forward.
On a de pop is also facing
two federal charges
for which he has not entered pleas on.
And he faces up to 50 years
in federal prison
for just those two charges.
Tomorrow is going to be
the next step in his court
proceedings here for those state charges.
We understand that he is not expected
to be in court.
It's going to be more
of a procedural hearing
where they're going to be setting dates
for the next step in this
in those state charges.
And what he's facing there on a.